Je vous garantis qu'à un moment donné,
tout ira vers le sud pour vous maintenant,
vous pouvez soit accepter cela, soit vous pouvez bien vous
mettre au
travail Je joue un astronaute vraiment ingénieux
qui se retrouve bloqué sur Mars,
il est laissé pour compte lors d'une
évacuation d'urgence de la planète
mal et elle finit par devoir laisser un
membre d'équipage derrière elle en le pensant mort, cela
va être un choc pour mes
coéquipiers mais je suis toujours en vie et maintenant
ils doivent trouver comment essayer de le
ramener à la maison maman il est toujours en vie
il a  pour essayer de comprendre comment sa
nourriture de voyous sur une planète où rien ne
pousse faisons le calcul j'ai assez de
nourriture pour durer 50 jours il va
mourir de faim bien avant que nous puissions aider
ce film fait un très bon travail de
pesée des choix les gens  doivent prendre et
mon gars a une de ces décisions
que vous ne risquez pas leur vie c'est
plus grand qu'une personne Non donc nous sommes en panne
et la NASA élabore ce plan pour essayer
de le récupérer si quelque chose ne va pas
nous mourons nous avions  non pas  son option
excellent casting et c'est excitant
parce que nous avons tous des emplois différents l'
équipe est fantastique l'équipe a rendu le
tout amusant je me suis bien amusé avec Ridley
j'ai adoré travailler avec eux j'ai
beaucoup appris le travail avec Ridley Scott dans un
film sur  l'espace coche en quelque sorte
toutes les cases ce que j'aime tellement dans le
film, c'est qu'il y a tellement d'
éléments qu'aucun homme ne peut rien faire
seul, il faut une équipe de personnes et quand
nous nous réunissons, nous pouvons vraiment
accomplir des choses merveilleuses c'est  pourquoi
nous voulions le faire juste pour mettre
quelque chose de positif dans le monde